[Music]
new book came out yesterday everybody's
talking about it arnold schwarzenegger
released his memoirs yeah always a good
idea it's called total recall my
unbelievably true
life story
there's arnold on the cover looking
ashamed for everything that's gone wrong
anyway this is a giant book it covers
his whole life
and i thought what better way to
celebrate this important literary work
than to hear excerpts from it read out
loud by our very own crappy arnold
impression choir directed by jimmy
vevino
[Applause]
i was born into a year of famine it was
1947
and austria was occupied by the allies
at one point we had seven cats we loved
the cats but never too much because
there was no such thing as going to the
vet i'd found a way to get to america by
the building
and i found a way to get into movies
movies would bring money
brigitte nelson and i had a heart affair
on the set of red sonja i was introduced
to eunice kennedy shriver maria's mother
and the first words i blurted out were
your daughter has a great ass
danny devito is the milton berle of
comic acting the t-1000 is made of
liquid meadow and can morph before your
eyes all of a sudden mildred and i were
alone in the guest house i also became
the proud owner of the world's first
civilian hunter it's not a tumor
your daughter has a great assist
thank you